he's got supporters Detroit New York Los
Angeles inciting large-scale rests and
sympathy marches I'm very aware of that
mr. Hoover what I do know he is lon
Ryland what I need to know right now
what's Martin Luther King about to do
next mr. president dr. King is here mr.
president in the South there have been
thousands of racially motivated murders
we need your help dr. Kang this thing's
just gonna have to wait it cannot wait
you've got one big issue I got a hundred
one somebody is here is the next great
battle Sam must've played they read dr.
King I tell you that white book and hit
you will not tolerate a jeté toes
attempted orchestrate a disturbance in
this state it is unacceptable that they
use their power and keep us voiceless
people actually they gonna kill our
children they're trying to get inside of
your head what happens when a man stands
up says enough is enough we built a pair
as we can rock by rock sale is proudly
but it probably we must mop come on
stand up you march those people into
rural Alabama it's gotta be open season
I have a word there's no words behind
there are 70 million people watching
these pictures are going round the world
we're gonna make a massive demonstration
white black and otherwise come the self
I heard about the attack of innocent
people I couldn't just stand by
I've seen the glory
what happens when a man stands up says
enough was enough